radish is an in-memory data structure
store
used as a database
cache and message broker following in
the footsteps of other nosql databases
such as cassandra couchdb and mongodb
redis allows the user to store vast
amount of data without the limits of
relational database
it supports various data structures such
as string hashes sets list
sorted sets bitmaps hyperlog logs and
geospatial indexes
if we talk about the architecture there
are two main processes in redis
architecture
one is redis client and the other is
redis server
this client and servers can be on the
same computer or to different computers
redis can also be configured as a master
slave configuration for the distributed
systems
talking about the advantages of redis
speed is the most important part of the
radius redis stores the whole data set
in primary memory that's why it is
extremely fast it loads up to 110 000
writes per second and 81 000 reads per
second can be retrieved it supports
pipelining of commands and getting and
setting multiple values in a single
command to speed up communications with
the client libraries talking about the
persistence redis shows all the data in
memory changes are asynchronously saved
on a disk using flexible policies based
on elapsed time and number of updates
since last save redis supports rich data
type it supports natively most of the
data types that developers already know
such as list sets sorted sets and hashes
this makes it easy to solve a variety of
problems as we know which problems can
be handled better by which data type all
the radius operations are atomic which
ensures that if two clients concurrently
accesses the radius server will receive
the updated value
the competitive advantages of radis is
that it provides multi-utility tools
that can be used in a number of use
cases such as caching messaging queues
any short-lived data in your application
such as web application sessions web
page hit counts etc i bet this is enough
to get you excited and start with
reddish on your next project now enough
jibber jabber let's get our hands dirty
while exploring radish
to install radisson system go to redis
dot io
download
once you go there you can find the
download information over here you can
download this stable version you can
download the docker file as well so that
you can run your radisson new docker you
can find the other versions as well okay
you can download the
zip file and you can unzip and you can
start your ready server and the other
way is you can download from your
package manager also so uh let's go and
download redis from the ubuntu package
manager so let's go to ubuntu so in your
ubuntu so run this command to
update your system first
sudo
apt
update
enter your password
and within no time your system will be
updated
okay now run
sudo apt
install
redis server
okay in my machine you can see that the
radius is already installed so it's
saying the latest version is installed
if your system doesn't contain redis
then the new then the new ready server
will be installed in your system
okay once the reddish is installed you
can start the radish server
by
redis hyphen server command
okay
you can see that
my ready server is started so this way
you can install and start your address
in your system
in this tutorial we will see how we can
use redis cli and check the first data
type that is strings so let's first
start the redis server in a background
process and open redis cli and use some
string commands so let's start ready
server in background
okay
so my ready server is started
okay you can see
from here
you can see that my ready server is
started
okay now let's open that is cli for
opening ready cli we'll just write
is cli
okay and hit enter you can see that once
you hit enter you can see that your
redis server information has been shown
here so this is running on your local
host and the port number is 6379 which
is the default port for radius okay now
here you can write all your radius
commas
so now let's start with strings quite
any strings in that is what we can do is
we'll just write set
string name
and the name
so you already know that tradies runs on
a key value pair okay so what we gave
here is name as a key and value of the
shabir and we are setting a string so
you can see that we return okay so that
means my chubby value is set into my key
name
okay if you want to see that what we can
do is get and the key
which we need to pass so we'll pass name
you can see that my value
is shown here okay let's add one more
variable
set email as
email at
domain.com
okay here the value is set
you can check that value as well and
give get email
okay now if you want the particular data
from this string okay how we can get is
you can from get range
and
the key you need to pass that is email
i want the first five characters okay so
i will pass zero to four
so you can see that i'm getting the
first five characters so this way you
can get all the characters different
characters from the
strings now we are just studying these
single single strings if you want to set
multiple strings how we can set this
using m set command using multiple set
we need to provide the key value pairs
so just we will provide here
lying as english this is one key value
pair the other value pair we can say
technology
technology is radius
so you can see two key value pairs we
are setting over here
okay
the same way we can get
multiple keys with m get command
we can pass multiple keys over here we
can pass lang and we can pass
technology
so you can see we got
both the values if you want to get the
length of a string with htr line command
we can get the length of the string as
well let's get the length of a length
key you can see that it's a 7 character
length
you can check for
technology as well okay so this way you
can check the length of the strings as
well
if you want to rename any of the keys
okay then
just
set the values again for that particular
key set key for the name
and i'm changing my name from shabby to
daily code buffer okay
you can see that the value has been
changed and if i get that value
the subject is changed to daily code
buffer so htr line will give this zero
as the length of a key when the key is
not present so if we
see abc abc the key is not present right
so at that time it will return zero
okay we can also store the integers as
well so let's store
set
count as one
okay so we'll get that integer when we
do get count
okay now we can increment and decrement
these values as well with the incr
command
incr and the key we need to pass that is
count so current my value is 1 right
when i do i ncr it will change to 2
so incr will always increment by 1 but
if you want to increment a particular
key by any of the particular amount so
for that you can use
incr by command
increment by and that you need to
give the key and by how much value you
need to increase so suppose i want to
increase by 10 so you can see that
my value is changed to 12
the same way you can use decr command
decrement so decrement the key
sorry decrement the count right so
decrement the count will change the
value from 12 to 11 and the same way you
can use decr by
to
pass the particular
values to decrement the value suppose i
want to decrement by 5 so you can see
that the values has been decremented we
can also store the float type values so
suppose
let's store
set pi as
3.14 okay so float tab values also we
can store you can see it's been stored
let's first clear out everything okay
let's do get pi again so you can see
that 3.14 has been set to my pi way so
if you want to increment the values of a
float type okay so for that we need to
do incr
by
float
okay increment by float and then you
need to pass the key that is my pi and
how much i need to increase suppose i
want to increase by 0.001
okay you can see that my new value is
3.4 double zero
and multiple characters that way
so
this way i can
increment now suppose i have some values
and i want to expire those values i want
to delete those values after some time
okay so for that we can expire those
values okay suppose i have one value a
which is set to one
okay you can see that my value is one
now i want to expire this value
after
expire a i want this values to be
deleted after 10 seconds okay so my
command would be expire 8 10 so after 10
seconds this value will be
deleted we can check this by ttl here
you can see that four second is
remaining
two second is remaining
minus two seconds that means this value
is expired
okay you can check the value again with
get a you can see the value is not there
by default the value would be -1
when the expiration is not set we can
set the expiration while setting the
variable
only so for that we'll do set x
and we will provide any key and will
provide how much seconds i want to keep
that value and
the value
okay so that means my b key would be
expired after 10 seconds till then i
will be having that value
okay till that if i do
b i have that value okay
if i check
what is the timing
okay it's been expired if i do again get
b that value won't be there
so that's it in this string in redis in
the next tutorial we will see list and
reduce
in this tutorial we'll be going through
list data type
so in the last tutorial we created many
of the keys over there so to list down
all the keys we can use keys command and
we can give the patterns
okay you can give the wildcard
characters or any of the particular
so i want to get all the keys which i
have already added so with this keys
star command
you can get all the keys so these are
all the keys which we added earlier okay
now to remove all the data
what we can use is we can do
flush all command so this will delete
all the
key value pairs from our radius okay now
if you see keys
star you can see that i don't have any
data now
okay now let's add some list
now to add any of the list variables the
command is l push
and the key value
so i'm putting my data into my country
key so country is the key and value
okay
you can see
that i have pushed you can push one more
data
country as usa
okay now to get all this data which we
have already entered we can use l range
and the key and start and stop
so this start and stop is the value
which we need to define to get the data
from the list so my start will be 0 and
my end would be
-1
to get all the data
you can see
i can get usan india let's add one more
okay
i'll push
uk okay
now
now you can see that with l range
country 0 minus 1 we are getting all the
data then i am adding l range country 0
to 1 so that means i will only get my
zeroth element and the first element
that should be uk and usf
okay so this way we can define the
range to get the data from our list
so if we
so we saw l push that is pushing from
the left side that means from the top
side
of our list so all the values you can
see we are adding at the top of the list
if we want to add the values at the
bottom of the list then we can use r
push so with the r push command
and now my country as a key
if i put my new
value then it will be pushed at the
bottom so currently you can see my
values are uk usa in india so australia
would be added at the bottom of india
okay so if i again check my
countries you can see that australia has
been added at the bottom
okay so this way we can use i'll push
and r push to add the data to our list
so currently you can see we have four
elements in our list okay you can use
ln length of the list command
to get the length of our list that is ln
and the key name
if the key name is not present it will
return 0 now if you want to remove the
data from our list
the same way we have l push and
r push the same concept we have for r
pop and l pop with l pop the data will
be removed from the top and with the r
pop data will be removed from the bottom
so the command would be l pop
and key that is my country so you can
see that
with lp command my uk would be removed
okay you can see that uk has been
removed with ipo command australia will
be removed now if you check our list
again you can see that we have only two
entries available so this way we can use
lpop and our pop command to remove data
from our list let's add one data
okay
i'll push
country
france
okay
let's clear this out sorry
and
do a range of country
with zero to minus one so we have
france usa and india now suppose you
want to change any of the value
okay you want to change france to any
other country so with the lsat command
in my key as country
and you need to provide the index which
index you need to change
okay it starts from zero so either zero
one or two we have suppose we provide
zero as france we need to change
let's change it to germany
okay you can see that reference has been
changed to germany with the lsat command
now you need to insert data at any
particular position okay suppose you
want to insert data between germany and
usa or usa and india or you need to
insert data before germany or after
india anywhere
so for that for that the command is l
insert and you need to provide the key
and you need to provide the command that
is before or after what you want to do
suppose i need to do before
okay i need to add before what before
germany
okay i want to add before germany and
what should be the value suppose
new zealand
okay
so you can see that i can add
new zealand at the top suppose i want to
add
after usa
okay so for that i'll insert country
after
usa i want to add any country suppose ui
okay so that will be inserted
after usa so this way you can use alien
set command to enter any of the details
at any position in our list
now you want to
find the values based on the index from
our list okay so for that the command is
l index
and the key we need to pass is our
country and what is the value at any of
the particular index suppose what is the
value at 3
you can see that at the 3 my value is ui
check with any of the value so this way
a linux command can be used to get any
of the value from the index
now we saw in the starting right we use
l push command
and we added country
and we added value
okay at the time what it happened is it
created a list and added the value to it
okay but what i want to do is i want to
check if that list exists then only add
the value into my list otherwise won't
add so for that my command would be help
push x
then my key
suppose
i'm adding data to movies currently i
don't have any movies list okay so i'm
using lpushx movies2
and adding any values
okay so it will return an
0 okay because it was not added to the
list but if we use l push x
for my
current list which is available and
if i add any new
country
okay
so at the time it will return the length
of the string so you can see that
without range
country right
so you can see that south africa has
been added the same way we have
our push x command as well
the same way as i'll push x
if you define any of the things
okay it will return 0 because
the movies list is not available yet you
can check with
l range command right
i'll range movies
0 to
-1 you can see that my list
is empty or doesn't exist
okay so this way we can use l push x and
r push x command to insert data into a
list when list is available so you can
see that we have data right in l range
for country
i'll range for country
zero minus one
so if you want to sort this data okay so
to sort this data we have a sort command
okay we need to provide the key and we
need to provide the pattern and limits
and all the many informations available
okay
here my list is of type string okay so
for that i need to provide alpha as a
command
to sort the data of my list so you can
see that
my data has been sorted
okay
now if you want to sort based on
descending order
you can sort that as well
so sorting of the list can be done that
way so if you have a list of numbers
okay that is of integer of any other
type you don't have to provide alpha as
a command while sorting the data now the
other command we have is
bl pop and br paw so what bl pop will do
is it will block the execution till it
has any value to remove okay if there is
any value in the list then it will
remove in the particular time frame
otherwise it will wait till the timeout
is been done to remove any element okay
so for that what we can do is let's open
one more terminal
okay
let's set bl pop
over here in bl pop let's add let's
specify any of the key
suppose i'm passing out
movies
we know that movies there is no data in
movies okay so i'm passing
one time or second
so it will wait for one second and
saying
data is nailed that means it was not
able to delete any of the data
okay
now if i add
movies for 10 second let's say 15
seconds so let's give bl pop movies 50
okay we are passing 15 seconds over here
and let's add
i'll push
movies abc
okay bx
you can see that
it removed movies abx okay so this way
the rpop is also available for the
blocking of removing the data from the
list so either of blpop or br pop can be
used according to the requirement so
these are all the commands that you can
use for the list in redis in the next
tutorial we will see how we can use sets
in redis
in the last tutorial we saw list and
readies in this tutorial we will be
looking into sets data type okay to
create any sets we'll use set command
okay and we'll pass key
and the members for the sets
suppose we have java okay you can see
one member is added
we can add multiple members
we can add
radish we can add multiple members
node.js
aws
okay this is we can add multiple members
as well
to list out all the members
we have s
members command and we need to pass
key so you can see that it will list all
the members available inside the
technology set the main advantage of set
is if you know from other technologies
or other languages as well sets will
store all the unique values if you are
trying to add the values which is
already been there in the key then it
won't affect that suppose
if you are trying to add
java again then there won't be a
duplication for that it will be always
the single you can see it's returning 0
so it's been not added to the set
so that's the advantage how it will work
so all the values will be unique
irrespective we saw in list there may be
duplicates as well to get the count of
members available inside your sets you
can use s card command and you need to
pass the key
okay you can see that it will return
four you have four members available
inside your technology set now to check
if any of the member is available inside
your set or not for that you need
command sys member
s is member or not
ss member then you need to pass key
that is technology and you need to pass
the member which member you are trying
to search suppose java
so it is returning one that means the
member is available
if you try anything else like spring
then it will
return 0 because it is not available
inside your set currently we have
node.js aws radius in java inside my
technology set let's create one more set
front-end okay for front-end
technologies and let's add some of the
members i'll add javascript
html
third node
yes
maybe react okay so these are the
members that i'm adding in my
front end list you can see by s members
i need to provide front end
you can see that these are the variables
available into my front end so currently
we have two sets that is one for
technology and one is front end to find
the difference between those two sets we
have sdif command
and we need to pass the key
technology and here the key is front end
so this will return the
differences
available within the two keys so if you
can see that with sdif command it will
check from the first key to the other
key so it will check what is the
difference okay so node.js it will check
nodejs is available inside my front-end
okay it's available so
it will be neglected
other things it will check aws is not
available
reduce is not available java also not
available so these are the differences
that is not matching to my second key
that is front end so these are the list
which will be printed out now if i want
to store this data inside any of the set
for that what i can do is s
diff
store command then i need to give
destination suppose
new set
okay then i need to pass the key
technology
and
front-end
so what i'm doing is i want to store the
difference from technology and front-end
which is this which we got right that is
java and aws to be stored inside my new
set key
okay previously we just displayed it
this we can do
to store the data okay the three
elements has been stored inside my
newsletter if you do s members
for
new set you can see that three values
are available
the same way we can check for the
intersection elements as well
so press enter
and you need to provide
p1 and key2 or many keys which is
available so if you can see i have
a center
technology i am passing and i am passing
front end
okay so you can see that the
intersection element from both the list
we have node.js so node.js is the common
element for both the sets so it's been
giving that well we can provide multiple
keys as well so if i provide technology
over here
front end over here and we have a new
set as well right so we provide new set
okay so this will return the data which
is been common to all so you can see
that there is no common data which is
available in all the list so it is
returning empty list now the same way
which we store difference data right as
diff store the same way we have as
interstore
to store the
differences of the data into new list so
new enter
is my destination and my key is
technology
and
front end is my t2
so you can see that the data has been
stored into a new list sorry new set
s members
new enter we can see that node.js has
been added to it let's clear it out
now let's list out all the members again
right yes
as members
technology
and
members
front end
now we saw the difference of the list
intersection of the list and the union
of the list we will see
so
s union is the command to
get the union of the two or multiple
list okay sorry multiple sets so for
that we are providing
as union and we need to provide key so
that is technology
and we are providing front-end
okay you can see that we are getting the
data which has been union so all the
data has been added we can provide
multiple keys as well
we have technology we have front end
we have
new set
we have new
intel okay so all will be merged up
together and the union will be displayed
to store all the union data we have as
union store
and we can store in union
new destination
let new union and we can provide
multiple keys let's add all these keys
right
and the new union seven elements has
been added to new union set we can see
all the members
oh yeah so this way we can do multiple
operations on set we did difference
operations we did union intersections we
added the elements we removed the
elements and multiple things okay so
that's been it it sets the next tutorial
we will see sorted sets
so in the last tutorial we saw sets in
freddy's in this tutorial we are going
to see what is sorted sets
sorted sets are very similar to sets
but with extra functionality which has
been sorted form sorted sets sorts
itself with an extra value which is the
score so when we add any of the values
to the sorted sets we will define this
score for that particular value so based
on the scores available the sets will be
sorted from minimum to maximum value of
the scores which we provide so let's add
some of the values to the sorted sets in
sets we were using set command to add
the value here for the sorted sets we'll
be using z command z a
double d
we'll start ready cli
okay and then we'll add
z
and key will provide
users and we'll provide this score which
is one and we'll provide the value
cover so you can see that the value has
been added we can add more values with
pipings as well like
z
the users will be key and we need to
provide the score and the value for it
x4 2
lx
3
nema
four steve
phi is nick
so all these values would be added based
on the scores which we provide and the
values will be sorted
accordingly we can see all the data with
the command z range and then we need to
provide the key which is users
and then we need to provide the start
and stop that means the minimum and
maximum value so 0 to minus 1 which we
will provide so you can see that all the
values are been stored and sorted based
on the scores which we have provided
okay if you want to see the scores as
well then we need to pass this with
scores
command as well so you can see that this
course has been added to get the count
of the users available or the
cardinality of the values available we
can use z card command
and we need to pass the keys
okay
you can see that there are five
variables available inside my
users we can use the z count command as
well
okay to get the count based on the rank
available so we need to add z count the
keys
which is my users and we need to pass
the rank which is the minimum and
maximum rank to get all the data we can
pass minus infinity to plus infinity
okay
minus n2 plus inf so it will get all the
data based on the negative infinity to
positive infinity
okay so you can see we have count as
five now if we need to provide any
particular values okay suppose i need to
get all the users with rank zero two
four
so you can see that we got four one
element is been missed out because we've
provided the maximum rank s4 we can
remove the elements with the command z
ram remove we need to pass the key which
is user and we need to pass the members
which member i need to remove suppose i
need to remove alex
i'll pass the alex and the alex will be
removed
if you see again
you can see that we have shabbir nema
steve and i miss paul denik okay that's
fine so these are my users available we
use g
range
users to get all our range right get all
the data but if you want to reverse it
you can use
z
reverse range
then keys
and we can give start and stop and with
scores if you want
with scores
so this will reverse the list you can
see that shabbir neema steve nick it is
reversed to next you neema and shabir so
this way we can reverse the range as
well to view it out based on the ranks
we can get the individual score also
that has been assigned to any of the
values suppose i want to get the score
of shabir okay so i can do z score
then my key as users
and i end a member number is subject
so you can see that i'll get the score
of it
we can pass any of the variables
let's get first team
so this way we can find the scores
assigned to any of the values so when we
did z reverse range okay so at the time
the reverse happened based on the rank
of all the particular values but if i
want to reverse based on the scores
which i provided so for that the command
is z
reverse
range by score okay we need to provide
users and we need to provide max and min
max five minutes zero
i need with scores
okay cool right so this will reverse my
set based on the scores which we
provided so from nick i should get
shabby you can see that right it's been
reversed now if i want to increment any
of the scores of any of the values okay
so how we can do
suppose i want to increase the score of
steve okay so for that the command is
z increment by z i and c are by e we
need to provide that is users
i need to increment by two what is the
member steve so i am incrementing
four to six score of steel
okay so you can see that the value is
six now
so you can see that if i am uh executing
the same command which i executed
earlier right for five to zero okay so
at that time steve is not coming
if i do six to zero then nick will be
coming so this is again do the commands
based on score now suppose if i want to
remove the values based on the scores
okay like minimum maximum value like i
want to remove nick and steve based on
the scores okay like if i have a long
range a long list the command is z
remove z ram
range
by
score
okay they remove range by score the key
is users
and the minimum value the minimum value
should be five maximum value should be
six so my five and six will be removed
okay if i do z range
users again with zero minus one you can
see that stevenic has been removed i
have two values available now if i want
to remove based on rank okay let's add
some more data see add users
5 cube
6 mr
7
early okay
z range users
zero to minus one okay these are the
scores as well now i want to remove
based on the rank so z remove range
by
rank okay the key would be users and
starting in stopping rank my rank
starting should be zero
i should remove till two
zero one and two
okay so three values has been removed
you can see that we have two values left
mri and alley so this way we can do
different operations on sorted sets
in the last tutorial we saw sorted sets
now in this tutorial we are going to see
what is hyperlog log data structure a
hyperloglog is a probabilistic data
structure used to count unique values
these values can be anything for example
ip addresses
for the visitors of a website search
terms or email addresses
are the unique count of locations and
many things so let's add some data to
hyperloglog and we can count and merge
the datas available inside different
hyperlogs now to add the data in the
hyperlog log the command is pf add
and the key i'm providing hsl
and the element suppose i'm adding any
value a
okay so this way the value is added we
can add piping as well we can add
multiple values like pfed
a
already there right p c d e
multiple values we can add
now what are the values available inside
my hhl so we can get with pf count
and the key
you can see that the seven values are
available
in my hsl
let's create one more okay pf head
hll2
and let's add
numbers in it
one two three four five six seven
okay we can get the count of that as
well pf
count hll2
okay this happened
now we can get the total account of all
the available hyperlogs as well
so we can do pf count
for hll
and hl2
this will provide the total count for my
both the hyperlog logs
we can also merge this
two or if we have multiple many of them
then we can merge them as well too into
a new one so pf merge is the command and
we need to provide the destination
will provide
merged hll
and we need to merge based on the
available which is hll and hll2
so this way both the data has been
merged to merge hll you can see merged
hli
sorry we need to do pf count
okay so this is you can see the count of
the new one so this way we can use
hyperlog logs for counting the sets for
the
different use case scenario as we saw
earlier
so in this tutorial we are going to see
hashes and radish so hashes is a map of
string keys and string values which is a
perfect example to store our objects so
let's create a hashes the command is h
set and we need to pass the key we are
passing my hash and the field name we
need to provide field name and providing
name
and the value as sugar
okay you can see that it returned once
so data is added let's add one more
values let's set
my hash
email
as
emaileddomain.com
so i've added name and email into my
hash my hash
okay now to get all the keys and values
from the hash the command is
h keys
and
key which is my hash
okay then it will return all the keys
available we have name and email
available over here right which we added
name and email so it will return all the
keys available in my hash
so to get all the values we can use
hvals command and we will pass my key
which is my hash so you'll get all the
values which you have added okay so
h keys will return all the keys and h
files will return all the values
available in the hash as get all command
will return all the keys and values
available in my hash in radish so we saw
three commands to get the values
available
in the hash as keys hmls and edge get
off but we need to check for the
particular values available so for that
the command is h exists and we need to
pass key which is my hash and the field
the field is name or email which we have
already so we will check with name
so it will return 1 when the value is
available it will return 0 when the
value is not available see if i check
with name one which is not there in my
hash so it will return zero so this way
we can check if the value is present in
hash or not we can also check the length
of the hash with hln command passing key
which is my hash
it will return the length so currently i
have two elements in my hash so it's
returning two suppose i'm adding one
more my hash i'm passing age
has 25
and if i do h line again it will return
three okay now here we can use
pipelining as well we can add multiple
key values inside my hashes so for that
the command is hm set and we need to
pass key which is my hash and we can
pass key value pass okay
suppose i'm passing country
as india
phone as
phone number
okay so this way the values will be
added the same way we can use hm get
command
to get multiple values out of the hash
the command is hmgat we need to pass
my hash as a key and we need to pass
multiple fields
i have name field i have email field and
phone you can see that all the values
have been written
okay the phone is wrong right it should
be capital
okay so this we can use hm set and hm
get to set and get the multiple fields
from the hash now suppose i want to
increment any of the values in my hash
then we can use h incur by command h i n
c r
by command we need to pass the key which
is my hash
and the field i have age added to it
right you can see i've added age so
let's increase the age
so i'll add age
and increment by two so you can see that
my age is 27 now okay so this way you
can use edge incur by command to
increase the values of the hash if you
want to increase the values with the
floating point data then also we can do
with h incur by float command and we
need to pass key which is my hash
field which is age
and increment the value like i'm adding
1.5 years okay so value is 28.5 so this
way h incur by float command is used for
floating point we can also remove the
elements with hdl key hdl command and we
need to pass the key which is my hash
and we need to pass field suppose h
let's remove the edge you can see it's
returning 1 that means the age is
removed we can again check with h exist
command with my hash
and h
it will return zero
okay age has been removed from the hash
we can use hstr line command to get the
length of any of the values so htr line
we need to pass key which is my hash and
we will pass the field suppose i need to
check the length of the name okay
so it is returning seven shabiri is of
seven characters so this we can use htr
line for finding the length of the
fields with h set nx command we make
sure that we will only add the fields
which is not available in my hash so it
won't override the fields so for that
reason we will use at saturnx command
suppose h7x will pass my hash
okay we will pass field suppose i'm
adding name name is already there i'm
just changing the name so this won't add
to my hash it will return zero you can
see that okay so it will always check if
value is available or not if value is
not available then only it will add
let's add the new value suppose i'm
adding last name
okay so it will return one and it's been
added to my hash so this way we can use
h7x command so that's been it in this
video in the next tutorial we will see
that is transactions
in this tutorial we are going to see
redis transactions you have already seen
that we are executing single single
commands in ready cli to get the job
done okay but what if we need to execute
multiple commands what if we need to
execute a bunch of commands in a single
go in a single file considering the
advantage of red is which is an
atomicity all the transactions all the
commands which we are executing should
be atomic if any error is there then all
the commands should not be executed so
that can be achieved using status
transaction to start a redux transaction
you need to specify a multi command once
you enter this command you are in a
transaction mode so all the commands
which you enter from now will be in the
queued state and it won't execute until
you specify a execute command okay let's
check it out we started a transaction we
are giving a bunch of commands like set
name as shabir
okay it's been queued
then you can see get name
that is also been queued
we'll do set
as one
set bs2
you can see all the commands have been
queued now all this command will be
executed in a single transaction when we
specify execute command this exec once
we fire this command all the commands
will be executed you can see that all
the commands have been executed so this
way a transaction has been created and
has been executed within a single flow
suppose you have created a transaction
right you are adding some commands get a
get c
get b any different commands you have
been executing okay by the mean time you
want to discard the transaction you
don't want to execute okay so for that
the command is
discard if you specify discard then all
the transactions all the commands that
you have been added to the transaction
all will be nullified okay your
transactions will be cancelled out so
this way you can execute a transaction
or a discarded transaction based on the
requirements now there is a special
command which is watch command if we
watch any particular key right if we add
a particular key in my watch and then we
create a transaction then what will
happen a transaction will be executed
based on the conditions for that
variable which has been added to the
watch if there is no change in the key
defined in the watch then only the
transaction will be completed if there
is any change in watch okay at that time
the transaction will not be executed and
it will return
but the change in watch should not be
within the current command line or
current client if it is coming from a
different client at that time only it
will check if there is any change in a
particular key from any other client if
so then the execution will be blocked
for the transaction so let's check that
out okay let's flush all our data let's
set
as1
let's open a new window new terminal
okay now i'm adding a multi command
okay i'm doing set bs to
get b
okay meanwhile i'm adding watch on a
okay watch oni has been added and i'm
doing execute command so you can see
that i have added watch on a but i
haven't changed that key a so for that
my current transaction will be executed
successfully you can see that i am
getting the data
in this tutorial we are going to see pub
sub in redis so pops up means publisher
subscriber model okay so we'll be having
a different channels where any of the
client can subscribe to it or any other
client can publish the messages to it so
let's subscribe to couple of channels
and within one client we will publish
the messages to those channels and we
will see how the messages are been
displayed so you can see i have three
clients open over here for readys from
two clients will be subscribing the
messages and from one client will be
publishing the messages okay so let's
subscribe to one channel suppose i'm
subscribing to
the subscribe command and the name of
the channel it's not necessary that
channel has to be created before you can
directly subscribe to it and later the
channel will be created that's also fine
so currently there is no channel created
i'm just subscribing to news channel
okay
once you do you can see that it's been
ready to read the messages and it will
only exit when you do ctrl c or quit the
command line or the client let's also
subscribe my other client
to news as well
sub
subscribe to news okay so my both the
clients has been subscribed to news and
let's publish the messages to news now
with publish command publish channel
name which is news
and we need to provide message the
message should be any message that you
need to do i'm providing
new breaking news okay
so you can see that it's showing to
which is mean it's been sent to two
subscribers okay you can see we are
getting over here and over here both the
places you're getting the data okay we
can add multiple messages
to news
new news
you can see that data is coming okay now
let's change the middle client and
change the subscription to multiple
channels okay i'm just quitting and
again opening ready cli
okay
and clearing out
and i'm subscribing to
news as well as
broadcast channel
so now it's been reading messages from
the two channels now publish to
broadcast as well
publish
news
n1 okay you can see that it's coming to
both if i do publish
to broadcast
new broadcast
okay sorry i did typo right
you can see that it's been coming here
okay now let's change this first client
and change to pattern-based subscription
okay
let's close it out again open ready cli
okay let's clear it out
okay now for pattern-based subscription
the command is p subscribe
okay so here we can give different
patterns for the different channels okay
there may be multiple channels so to
subscribe to those channels we can give
patterns over here if the pattern is
matching then it will subscribe to those
channels and the messages will be read
from those channels so for news right
instead of news let's add news star okay
so that means if there is any multiple
news like news one news two news three
news hello anything okay then all those
channels will be subscribed okay with
stars so star is a wildcard character
and it can be specified as any of the
character let's subscribe to one more
which is
hello okay suppose i just want to match
for the single characters okay
like
this hello so if we are passing this way
then it will be subscribed to hello
hello that question mark can be replaced
with any single characters over there
okay we can also add few of the
characters to it if the character is
matching then like if i want to match
ball and bill okay then i can add this
way
it should be matching with ball and bill
okay so this way particular characters
will be matched
so this way we can subscribe to multiple
channels
with
patterns you can see that i'm subscribed
to this channel now let's add the
messages i'm publishing the messages to
news channel
with hello so you can see that in both
of the clients i'm able to receive the
messages so news star is working this
way now suppose i am publishing the
messages to
hello channel
with message hello okay you can see that
we have added h question mark hello so
if you enter this you can see that we
are listening to that as well
if i publish to h x
double l low right
so i'm just changing that character and
i'm passing that message
i'm able to receive the messages for
that particular subscription let's check
for bill and ball as well
let's publish the messages to ball
new ball
you can see that i am able to get
furball the same way let's check for
bill as well
you can see that all is working if i add
anything else
you can see that is returning zero so
it's been not subscribed and no one has
been receiving those messages for pull
so this way we can specify different
patterns for the subscription of the
channels
now let's check some of the pub sub
commands okay
so pubsub command and the sub commands
for channels okay
now pub sub channels will return all the
channels that have been subscribed which
is not a pattern based subscription okay
so if you can see that with pub sub
channels command i'm getting broadcast
and news that means those two channels
has been subscribed the rest of the
channels are being subscribed based on
the patterns so that's why i'm not
getting hello or bail or ball okay so
pop sub command for channels you will
get all the channels the next command is
pub sub and
num sub so this will define number of
subscriptions for that particular
channel so if i check for news okay
so you can see that it's been returning
one so only one client is being
subscribed to news channel okay you can
see that still my patent-based
subscription is not coming over here
okay so it will only fetch all the
non-patent-based subscription for the
channels so this is your pub sub
channels command and pub sub num sub
command we can also check number of
pattern based subscription with
pub sub
numpad
okay this will written all the pattern
based subscription for the channels okay
you can see that there are three pattern
based channels that have been subscribed
you can see that is new star h question
mark double hello and bell or ball which
has been subscribed so this way we can
check all the different pub sub commands
all the subscribers available within the
different clients for my radish so
that's been it in this tutorial in the
next tutorial we will see scripts and
readys
in this tutorial we are going to see
scripts in radish most tasks you do in
red is involve many steps instead of
doing these steps in the language of
your application you can do it inside
that is with lua this may result in
better performance also all the steps
within scripts are executed in an atomic
way no other radius commands can run
while a script is executing so the
command is eval
and we need to pass the scripts so we
can pass any of the functions available
inside redis library are the lua
scripting libraries okay so we'll be
using radish library functions
that is redis dot call
inside that will be passing the commands
and the keys and values available so i'm
using set and i'll be using keys which
we will be passing as an arguments
we'll also use argb argument variables
which will be passing okay and the
number of key value pair is one okay so
we'll be providing one if you are not
passing anything you can provide zero
and you need to pass the key which is
name
and
variable
you can see that command is executed you
can get the name you can see shabbir has
been returning okay now how this works
the ul command is what tells redis to
run the script which follows by redis
dot call which is the internal redis
library methods or functions which are
available there are multiple lua
functions also available for the
scripting currently we have here
redis.call which have three commands
that is set keys of one argv of one
which are string is our scripts which is
functionally identical to the radishes
set command okay three parameters
follows the script text which is the
number of provided keys which is one the
key name which is name and the first
argument which is the shabir the value
of the key so this way my command is
executed we can add we can check one
more command by passing multiple values
okay so let's add
eval
with
radish dot call
okay
we'll pass that
okay let's use m set command to set
multiple strings okay and then we'll be
using
keys of 1 and then
argument 1
then keys of 2
argument of 2
so i i'm using m set command passing key
one value one key to value two
yeah i need to pass number of keys i'll
be using two keys okay for key one and
key two then i need to define two keys
i'm specifying
name as one key and
last name as another key now followed by
these two we need to pass
argument one and argument two so i'm
passing shabir
and i'm passing the way so this is the
command my name
and last name are the key 1 and k2 will
be replaced in the radius.call function
in the same way irg1 and argv2 both the
arguments will be replaced with shabir
and
you can see that command has been
executed if i check the values
get
last name you can see that it's coming
down okay now let's take up one notch
above so i'm executing this command okay
which is hm set country capital i'm
passing bunch of countries and capitals
okay india for new delhi us usa
washington dc russia is a moscow german
is berlin japan stockholm italy's room
so this is creating my set with all the
country and country capitals detail
okay and let's add one more sorted set
so i'm creating a sorted set of country
and i'm passing three countries italy
india and usa with the scores available
okay you can see that
z range of country
zero to minus one so we have three
countries india italy and usa now what i
want is i want the capitals
from my ad set based on the values
available in my country sorted set okay
so i want all the values like for my
italia i want rome for india i want new
delhi for usa i want
washington dc but i want all the details
from that hash for this particular set
within the same sequence okay so let's
write a script for it so we'll be
writing eval okay and we'll start the
script we'll be using
redis dot call
we'll be doing
z range
for
keys we provide okay
so whatever
set we provide
and i want all the values so for 0 to
minus 1 all the value okay
now let's store all these values in our
local variable so i'm creating a local
variable
order
okay i want that in this order so i
created this variable now with this
order let's get all the data from edge
set
that is the country cap which we created
so we'll be doing
return
redis dot call
i'll be needing multiple keys so i'll be
using hm get
i'll use
keys of two i'll pass the second
argument as the hash key okay and then
what i'll do i'll use the luas function
for
table that is unpack
and then in unpack i'll pass my local
variable which is order
okay and then i'll specify number of
keys which is 2
and then i'll pass key 1 my key 1 should
be country right
because my country is my set so i need
to pass set over here and for key 2
it should be country cap
okay you can see that i got all the
details rome new delhi and washington dc
for italy india and usa with the same
sequence based on the values of the hash
and sorted side okay so this we can use
different scripts available this is just
the gist of the lua scripts which we can
use in redis there is a lot more we can
do you can for sure go to the lua's
website and you can learn the lua
scripts and you can use android is now
let's do one more thing now to rather
than writing entire script over here
right we can store that script and we
can execute those scripts okay so let's
do that okay so this is my entire script
from here to here
right now let's load the script okay
script load command
and this value you can see that once we
load the script we will be getting a
hash value okay so entire script is
stored in this hash so we can evaluate
with this to execute this hash scripts
we need to use
eval sha command okay after that we need
to pass the shaky and then we need to
pass the arguments so previously we
passed to country and country cap okay
so same we can pass over here my key
is two i have two keys available so
and the first key should be country and
the second should be
country cap
okay i'm getting the same results over
here okay i can also check if my script
is available for the particular hash
available
okay this is my hash so let's check if
script is available currently we have
the script so it will be available
so the command script
exist and we need to pass hash
so you can see it's returning one so the
script is available with the script
flush command all my scripts will be
flushed out and see okay now if i check
again if script is exist or not then it
will return zero my script has been
deleted so this way we can use scripts
in redis we can load the different
scripts we can remove it we can check if
existence is there or not we can create
the entire lua scripts as well and we
can entirely run those rua files as well
so i recommend only using scripts when
you can prove that it results in better
performance so always run benchmarks
first for the scripts also your script
shouldn't be too long remember that
while script is running everything else
is waiting for it to finish so if your
script takes quite some time it can
cause bottlenecks instead of improving
performance and the script stops running
reaching the timeout so the default
timeout is for five seconds okay so
that's been it for the scripts and
readys in the next tutorial we will see
connections and security
in the last video we saw about scripting
and release in this tutorial we are
going to see connections and security in
redis so once you're connected to your
redis client is your connection is
successful or not to check that you can
use a ping command okay once the
connection is successful server will
return you pawn okay it's a nice game so
you can play ping pong with redis client
we can add the messages as well with
echo command
with any of the message it will be
displayed in the
client okay so in redis there is a
concept for databases there will be
different databases available the
default database when a client is
started then it's assigned as 0. to
select that the command is select to
select any of the database and we need
to provide the index of the database
default will be always zero so you can
see that when you do again select zero
it will return okay your zeroth database
will be added if you want to change the
database you can add select one then it
will change to the newer index database
you can always switch and forth between
them despite of different databases
available all the data are persisted
into a single rdb or aof file in the
radish okay in a single node
architecture if there is a clusters
available if your radius is configured
in a cluster then by default every time
your database will be zeroth index you
cannot change it at that particular time
so this is only available when you are
running on a single node and the main
important part is when you are switching
between the databases when you are using
select zero or select one with either
zero or one databases then your keys
will be unique to each of your database
so if you are adding one key to database
0 then that particular key won't be
available to database 1. if it's there
then value if you are adding to it it
may be different so let's check it out
so currently i mean select zero so i'm
adding
set
name as shabir
okay you can see that
get name is available for shabbier now
let's switch it to
index one okay database one and then if
i do get name
you can see that it's returning nil okay
so that means it's not affecting to my
the select zero database let's set this
value over here
set name to
the audi
if i again check that name
is
and if i check the same name again in
zero database
changing back to zero index and checking
the name
you can see that both the values are
different one is now the and one is
shabby in both the zero and one database
so in the reddit server multiple redis
clients will be connected to the reddish
server so
what are all the clients available you
can check by the command client
list
okay so this will return all the clients
which have been listed over here you can
see that all the informations are
available their id their address
their name
their agent all the different things are
available currently i have only one
client enabled so that's why only one
entry is coming if multiple clients are
available multiple entries will come
okay you can also set the name of the
client you can see that currently the
name is nalo yeah so we can set the name
as well so let's add client
set name as this terminal
you can see that
the name is set you can also get with
client get name
that particular name okay now when we
check for client list again okay at the
time you can see that that name value is
coming for the listed clients so this
way we can identify which client has
been active and which client we need to
kill or any other operations if you want
to do for the particular client if you
want to kill those clients we can use
the kill command to kill the clients
okay
the command is client
kill and we can kill based on the id so
we need to provide id and the id which
is your 17 okay and if you want to do by
address then you need to pass the
address which is over here to kill that
client i'm passing 17 over here you can
see that okay currently i'm running in
this so it won't be deleted
let's clear it out so this way we can
use different client keys as well over
here now coming to security we can
define the password for the clients to
login to your server okay so for that we
need to check the configuration we need
to change the configuration for it so
let's change the configuration for
storing the password we'll do config
set
require pass okay so this is the require
pass is the configuration for setting
the password here we need to set any of
the password so let's
set submit one two three okay so you can
see that password is set so once the
password is set now you cannot execute
any of the command without
authenticating to your client okay
if i open any new terminal
okay and i do
get name you can see that error is
coming north authentication required so
unless you are authenticated you cannot
execute commands over here so to
authenticate you need to use auth
command
auth and you need to give password so
the password we set was
shabbat one two three right shabbit one
two three so once you are authenticated
then you can
check your commands will be executed
properly so this way you can use
authentication to connect to your radius
clients as well so that's it in this
video for connections and securities in
radish
in this tutorial we are going to see
geospatial commands so in geospatial
command what we store is we store a
location information we store lat long
details of any of the particular
location we say lat long but if you are
aware of all the geometrical aspects or
geography then the details which have
been expressed is longitude and then
latitude x and y axis okay so we'll be
storing the data as longitudes and
latitudes so how red is stores all these
information so that it stores all this
data in a sorted set but if you remember
that in our previous tutorials we saw
that sorted sets to store the data we
specify
scores okay based on this course data
has been added so here the scores has
been added based on the jio hash
generated based on the latitude and
longitude information which we provide
so it generates a 52 bit integer value
based on that the geo hash is generated
jio hash will be a unique value based on
that location based on that data has
been stored into the sorted sides okay
and the model here is used as a
spherical model the earth which has been
modelized in radish is a sphere okay so
all the data which we are storing will
have a prone to 0.5 percent of errors so
make sure of that while using that is in
your application for geospatial data so
let's start adding locations into our
radish the command here to add the
information of latitude and longitude is
jio ad
okay
and then you need to specify the key
suppose i'm specifying key as maps
okay and then you need to provide
longitude and latitude information okay
so here are my latitude and longitude
information uh so this is the city
amdhabad so i'm storing the information
longitude and latitude of am the birth
city you can see that the data has been
entered now let's add some more data for
different cities okay we can use
pipelining also over here when adding
location data okay so this is the
command jio add maps using the same key
and i'm adding the
longitude and latitude for mumbai and
the same for bangalore okay
so you can see that i have added the
data let's check the data now to get the
data right you can use all these similar
sorted set commands okay because pin
functions are stored in sorted sets so
we'll see the range
maps
and we'll
provide the start and end index
you can see that bangalore mumbai and
amnabad is added to it now i told you
right in the starting that all the
informations are stored based on the jio
hash values okay so uh let's check the
geohash values for the sorted elements
to check the jio hash values we can see
with command jio hash
okay and we need to specify the key
which is maps and you need to specify
the member for which member you need to
see that suppose i want to see for
ahmadabad okay
you can see that this is the hash key
which is been generated now if you are
not aware of what jio hash means then
you can go to wikipedia and
check on geo
there is also website called geohash.org
that will take jio hash value as an
input and it and it will
show the location information i can show
you that as well
you can see
your hash.org
if you go
okay if i specify here
jio hash value then you can see and the
word is being shown over here okay so
this way you can check the geohash
values and the coordinates for it okay
now getting back to business now we
stored our values we got the jioh values
as well okay but what about getting back
the values okay so the command to get
the values like my longitude and
latitude value okay the command is
geopos
okay and you need to specify maps that
is a key and you need to specify the
member
okay that will return your longitude and
latitude values which you specified now
you can see that the values which we're
getting here is different than what we
have stored right because i told you
that earlier it converts into a 52-bit
integer and then it's storing these
values okay so there might be a 0.5
percent of errors so these are the
values been stored you can get this
information from here as well now we
store three locations okay let's add one
more location okay i'm adding pune as
well giving longitude and latitudes for
that as well
now if you see
my data
i have four locations okay i have added
my latitude longitudes now i want to
find the distance between those two
locations okay that the command to get
the distance between two location is
geo dist
okay geodes command and then you need to
specify
your key and you need to specify the
members you can only get distance
between two members only not more than
that so suppose i want to get the
distance between mumbai and pune okay
mumbai and [ __ ]
okay so you can see that you're getting
the distance over here the default unit
for the jio dist is meters so you're
getting this in meters okay now if you
want in specific units you can specify
it if you want in kilometers
okay so this is the information in
kilometers so there is 120 kilometers of
distance between mumbai and pune if you
want
you can get in miles as well with mi
okay so this is the distance between the
two
cities in mice you can get in meters as
well
okay so this way you can find the
distance between two cities
you can specify for others as well you
can specify for
mumbai and ahmedabad in kilometers okay
you can see that it's 441 kilometers now
be sure that there might be some of you
who will be specifying okay the distance
between two cities is not that which we
are getting in google maps it won't be
because the distance between the two
cities which has been calculated by
radius is based on the two points so it
will be a straight line between the two
points and the straight line will be
based on the sphere model okay so the
distance is calculated on this sphere
model between the two points with a
straight line so that's how radius
calculates the distance between the two
locations now i got the distance now i
want to find the
locations around a particular point okay
suppose we can take a scenario like i
want to find the restaurants nearby okay
so i have my current positions i have
all the positions of restaurants as well
so i want all the restaurants nearby
area suppose 200 meters or maybe 50
meters okay or maybe all the restaurants
in the city so all these informations i
can get with the help of jio radius
command i have all the information
stored okay you can see i've just stored
information of map you can store all the
information for all the particular
restaurants all the different use cases
what you have so here what we'll do we
will find the cds specified to the
location okay within this location
within the radius of this location how
many cities i'm getting so that
information will find out with
your radius command
okay
your
radius command and then i need to
specify the key which is maps
then i need to specify the
longitude and latitude information okay
suppose i want to find nearby cities for
that particular radius from m in the bar
so suppose i will give the latitude and
longitude for amdapod
and then i can specify the radius value
so within how many kilometers or meters
or feet or miles you can see all the
information you can provide so i want
all the cities within 500 kilometers
okay
so i'm getting two cities which is
ahmedabad and mumbai ahmedabad would be
zero zero kilometers for sure and mumbai
would be you can see it will be 441
kilometers so all these informations you
are getting from here if i change my
kilometers okay supposed to 1000
kilometers you can see that i am getting
more data pune is also included in it
okay
the same way you can calculate in miles
as well okay within thousand miles of
radius you can see within thousand miles
of radius all the information all the
cities are being included bangalore
mumbai pony and okay now there are some
more keys also we can specify we can get
all the coordinates as well with r and
we can get distance as well okay so for
that we need to pass with
with coord right so you can see that
we'll get the coordinates information as
well for ahmedabad these are the
coordinates for bangalore these are the
coordinates for mumbai and pune
accordingly
okay if you want coordinates as well as
distance also okay so you need to
specify with a dist so you can get the
distance as well for amdava this is this
is 0.0001 mile the same for bangalore
mumbai
and pune all the information you can get
now there is also one command to get
with hash okay
so there is one catch over here okay if
you do with hash and hoping okay you
will get that jio hash value okay and
you are out of your luck because radius
doesn't store that information so this
value would be your 52-bit integer that
has been stored for the sorted cell
right that value it will be you can see
that that integer will be this not your
jio hash values
okay so for getting your values you are
with geohash commands only good luck
with that so this way you can get the
informations based on the longitude and
latitude for your particular location
but what if you want to get data within
the radius based on the members which
you have already in your key
okay so for that the command is let's
clear it out everything first okay so
for that the command is
jio radius
by
member
okay
your radius by member is a command then
you need to specify the key which is
maps and then you need to specify a
member suppose
okay
so my point starting point is ah and
within the ramdabad i want a radius and
that information i want i want radius of
500 kilometers
okay
and then you can see that you will get
the information based on the member
values
you can always specify
more information so this information you
will get
up to feeds level okay
you can specify feet meters kilometers
and miles so within the area and within
the use case what you have you can get
the information based on this geospatial
commands here as well in geo reduce by
member you can specify with chords with
dist and with hash values
and with this you can also specify how
data you want okay by ascending order or
by descending order so you can specify
the esc to get data in descending orders
with the maximum value first
so bangalore is the farthest from
ahmedabad followed by pune and mumbai
and you can change to ascending order as
well
to get data from the nearest to the
mdhabat followed by mumbai pune and
bangalore so these are the details of
all the command that you can use to
store your geospatial or geographical
values and you can perform your
operations and you can use in your use
cases so that's been it in this video
for geospatial commands and reduce
in the last tutorial we saw geospatial
commands and readies in this tutorial
we'll be seeing redis benchmarking we
are in home stretch now benchmarking is
very important thing whenever we decide
to use a new technology or use new tool
then how the tool or technology is
performing for our application or for
our use cases that will play a huge role
in going ahead with that technology or
tools okay here redis provides an
inbuilt tool that is redis benchmark to
benchmark how radius will perform on our
server or how it will perform on our on
our single node or a cluster so that way
we can get our expectations clear how
radius will be performing and we can
optimize it or we can check if new nodes
or new servers would be needed to get
the desired performance in our
application or not so let's check how we
can do benchmarking in radius one protip
yeah till now you have seen that we are
connecting to redis cli with our only
ready cli command so we are connecting
to just our local host which we have
installed in our machine but what if you
want to connect to any of the server
okay so for that we need to specify the
host name or the ip address and the port
number so the command would be
redis cli
and then we need to pass host number
that would be i'm connecting i'm still
connecting to my local or so i need to
pass my localhost url which is my local
skype is 127.0.0.1
and then we need to
pass the port number so my redis was
working on port number 637 and which is
the default port for ids okay so this
way you can connect to any of the remote
redis servers okay you can see that i
have connected to
redis now so let's cancel it out and go
with the benchmarkings
okay for the benchmarkings also the same
thing if you're running on your local
system on your system where the redis is
installed you can directly go ahead with
ready siphon benchmark command you don't
have to specify any of the parameters
but if you are running on any of the
servers then you need to specify your
ipn port number with hyphen h and hyphen
p parameters okay so let's do redis
benchmark okay now we need to specify
some of the parameters how we need to do
benchmarking with what number of data
with what number of lines and all the
different informations so if you don't
specify anything at that time it will
french benchmark on all the different
commands available with 50 clients and
three bytes of data default okay but i
need to specify for maybe thousand
commands okay so i need to specify
hyphen n
and
i'll specify thousands so it will run on
1000 commands so you can see that
benchmarking is completed okay so it's
running on 1000 commands you can see
1000 operations with 50 parallel clients
and three bytes of payload
okay you can see all the different
informations for set command how much
time it took okay 31 250 requests per
second it can perform okay with three
bytes of data the same way you can check
for get and all the different
information okay let's clear it out
again now you saw right we had only
three bytes of data suppose i want to
run the command for more data okay so
for that i need to pass the data
information that is hyphen d and i need
to specify the size okay i'm specifying
100 kb so what it will run now is
benchmarking will run for thousand
commands with 100 kb of data
so you can see that all the operations
have been running for i'll push our push
all the different commands it will check
how it's behaving okay it's set and all
different informations have been loading
up so this way you can check the
benchmarking for a system let me cancel
it for now
okay
and then check how it was behaving
if we scroll it up you can see that
oh
boy so much information right
yeah
you can see that thousand request
completed in 0.03 seconds and it is
showing 50 parallel clients and how much
period it is okay we change the payload
from 3 bytes 200 kb so accordingly you
can get the value right it will take
around 830 request per second for
setting the data
80788 for getting the data for
incrementing your values 344 82 request
per second and all the different
information you will get and accordingly
we can get the idea how redis is
performing okay let's clear it out all
the details
okay
so this way we gave this information and
we saw that the default lines were 50.
now if you want to change the clients
right
then we need to specify hyphen c command
and then we can specify how much client
we need to
check
you can see that we specified 200 lines
okay so it's running on it will run on
200 clients so again it will show the
same informations how much number of
requests has been served per second
you
[Music]